Willkommen an der Militärakademie in Wiener
Neustadt! Mein Name ist Oberst Markus Reisner,
ich bin der Leiter der Entwicklungs- und
Forschungsabteilung der Militärakademie und
in unserem heutigen dritten Video wollen wir
uns mit der militärischen Lage in der Ukraine
befassen. Hier wollen wir die wesentlichen
Probleme ansprechen und Herausforderungen,
die die ukrainischen Streitkräfte zurzeit zu
bewältigen haben. Sehen wir kurz auf die Karte
der Ukraine und auf die eingesetzten Kräfte von
russischer und ukrainischer Seite. Hier haben
wir einmal eine Manövergruppe der russischen
Streitkräfte im Bereich nördlich von Kiew
mit Hauptangriffsziel Kiew. Ostwärts davon haben
wir eine operative Manövergruppe im Raum südlich
Kursk mit Angriffsziel einmal über Sumy und
einmal in Richtung Charkiw. Südostwärts davon,
aus dem Raum Rostow antretend, haben wir
eine Manövergruppe, die den Auftrag hat,
die Kontaktlinie im Norden und im Süden
zu umfassen. Südlich davon, auf der Krim,
ebenfalls eine Manövergruppe, die den Auftrag hat,
mit zwei Stoßen - einmal im Nordwesten und einmal
im Nordosten - in das Land weiter vorzustoßen.
Als weiteres, fünftes Element interessant ist
die Verfügbarkeit von Kräften im Raum Brest. Hier
wissen wir, dass einige Elemente verfügbar sind.
Wir wissen aber nicht, was hier der Auftrag
dieser Teile ist. Aus dieser Situation und aus
der derzeitigen Lage, die sich grob so darstellt
wie blau eingezeichnet, kurz die Kernprobleme,
die die ukrainischen Streitkräfte im Moment
haben. Beginnen wir mit der ersten Herausforderung
im Raum Kiew: In Kiew war es die Idee, am
Beginn, in den ersten Morgenstunden des 24.
Februar rasch eine Entscheidung herbeizuführen.
Dazu haben die russischen Streitkräfte die 31.
Luftlandebrigade am Flugplatz Hostomel angelandet,
mittels Hubschrauber, und versucht, diesen in
weiterer Folge durch den Einsatz von schweren
Transportmaschinen Il-76 mit weiteren Kräften zu
nähren. Das hat nicht funktioniert, denn aufgrund
des starken Gegenfeuers der ukrainischen Kräfte,
vor allem mit Fliegerabwehr-Lenkwaffen, ist es
nicht gelungen, diesen schweren Transportmaschinen
auf Hostomel anzulanden und die Luftlandekräfte
waren alleine auf sich gestellt. Ein Gegenangriff
der 4. ukrainischen mechanisierten Brigade hat
dazu geführt, dass diese russischen Kräfte an
den Flugplatzrand im Norden zurückgedrängt worden
sind und dadurch ein entsprechender Zeitverlust
entstand. Dieser Zeitverlust entstand vor allem
dadurch, dass diese Kräfte warten mussten,
bis sich die mechanisierten und motorisierten
Kräfte, aus dem Norden über Tschernobyl antretend,
mit ihnen wieder vereinigen konnten. Diese
Verzögerung war entscheidend, denn es ist nicht
gelungen, eine rasche Entscheidung am Beginn der
Einsatzführung herbeizuführen. Unabhängig davon
bleibt das die erste Kernherausforderung: Die
Ukraine muss Kiew so lange wie möglich halten,
denn das ist das politische und militärische
Zentrum des Landes. Ein Fall von Kiew hätte
möglicherweise einen devastierenden Effekt
auf die weitere Einsatzführung. Die zweite
Herausforderung, die die ukrainischen Streitkräfte
haben, sehen wir im Osten des Landes. Hier ist
es so, dass die Kräfte aus dem Raum Rostow aber
auch aus dem Raum südlich von Kursk ihre Angriffe
begonnen haben. Circa zwei bis drei Tage waren
die Russen damit beschäftigt, den sogenannten
Angriff zum Durchbruch durchzuführen. Das heißt,
sie haben sich langsam durch die ukrainischen
Verteidigungsstellungen durchgekämpft. Da kam es
zu wesentlichen Verzögerungen, aber nach diesen
drei Tagen war es so, dass sie mit den Kräften
eine weitere Operation in der Tiefe durchführen
konnten. Das heißt, die Kräfte bei Sumy haben Sumy
links liegengelassen und sind weiter Richtung Kiew
vorgestoßen und Charkow wurde umfasst und ein
weiterer Vorstoß in die Tiefe des Landes Richtung
Poltawa beziehungsweise Richtung Südosten ist
erfolgt. Die Manövergruppe im Raum Rostow,
auch genährt durch die separatistischen Kräfte,
hat versucht, einerseits die ukrainischen Kräfte,
die Masse der Kräfte, hier im Osten der
Ukraine zu binden, vor allem durch massive
Angriffe durch Mehrfach-Raketenwerfer und
einmal im Norden und einmal im Süden die
beiden Oblaste Donezk und Luhansk zu umfassen.
Hier hat es in den letzten Wochen sehr heftige
Kämpfe gegeben und die Fortschritte wurden vor
allem dadurch verringert, dass hier ausgedehnte
Verteidigungsanlagen vorhanden sind, die
zu überwinden waren, unter anderem auch
Minenfelder. Im Süden ist die Situation wie folgt:
Hier haben wir die Kräfte der Krim, die zwei Stöße
durchgeführt haben - einmal über den Dnjepr bei
Cherson und einmal nordostwärts davon weiter
Richtung Saporischschja und Richtung Mariupol, um
hier einerseits eine Einkesselung und Einnahme der
Stadt Mariupol zu erreichen beziehungsweise
im Raum Cherson den dort wichtigen Kanal,
der Frischwasser vom Dnjepr Richtung Krim bringt,
in Besitz zu nehmen. Kommen wir kurz zur dritten
Herausforderung, die seit Beginn besteht. Das ist
die Situation der Kräfte in Brest. Hier wissen wir
nicht, ob diese möglicherweise auch einen Ansatz
durchführen. Dieser muss gar nicht so weit in die
Tiefe gehen, wie eingezeichnet, also über Lemberg
hinaus, sondern es würde reichen, auch nur einen
Angriff mit begrenztem Ziel durchzuführen. Das
würde vor allem hier in diesem Raum dazu führen,
dass jene ukrainischen Bevölkerungsanteile,
die von der Ostukraine bereits in den Westen
geflüchtet sind, möglicherweise weiter in Panik
verfallen und versuchen, das Land zu verlassen,
weil sie natürlich durch diesen möglichen Ansatz
das Gefühl haben, dass der Sack zugemacht wird.
Kommen wir nun aber zum vierten Problem
und das ist eigentlich im Moment die größte
Herausforderung. Diese spielt sich im Süden des
Landes ab, wo die Masse der Blicke gar nicht hin
ausgerichtet ist. Diese vierte Herausforderung
besteht im Raum Mykolaiv. Tatsächlich bietet sich
für die weitere Einsatzführung der Dnjepr als
starke Verteidigungslinie für die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte an. Das heißt, das Problem ist,
wenn sie ihre Kräfte aus dem Osten nicht über
den Dnjepr zurücknehmen können, dass diese Kräfte
im Wesentlichen eingekesselt werden. Sprich:
Problem Nummer zwei. Das Problem Nummer
vier, das jetzt aber seit mittlerweile
mehreren Tagen besteht, ist, dass es den Russen
bereits gelungen ist, den Dnjepr zu überschreiten,
und man hier zwei Vorstöße erkennen kann: Einmal
Richtung Nordosten. Hier ist sicherlich das Ziel
ein wichtiges Atomkraftwerk einzunehmen ("Ukraine
Süd"). Nach der Einnahme eines Atomkraftwerks
im Raum südlich Nikopol wären somit 8 von 15
Reaktoren in russischer Hand und damit 60 Prozent
der elektrischen Energieversorgung. Der zweite
Stoß, der sich aus dem Süden entwickelt, das ist
jener Stoß, der in die Tiefe des Landes geht und
zwar hinter den Dnjepr, womit das Problem besteht,
dass die Kräfte im Osten, die nur bei Dnipro
und bei Saporischschja den Dnjepr überschreiten
können, möglicherweise auch in der Tiefe umfasst
und eingekesselt werden. Diese vier Kernprobleme
gibt es zurzeit aus ukrainischer Sicht zu bewerten
und danach zu handeln. Das Problem ist, dass das
Problem Nummer 4 nur gelöst werden kann durch
einen massiven Gegenangriff von mechanisierten
Kräften. Dazu müsste aber zumindest temporär ein
gewisses Maß an Luftüberlegenheit verfügbar sein,
das offensichtlich nicht besteht. Wir sehen zwar,
dass die ukrainischen Streitkräfte sehr tapfer vor
allem im Osten des Landes kämpfen. So gelingt
es ihnen im Norden und Nordosten immer wieder,
die Versorgungsrouten der russischen Kräfte
empfindlich zu stören. Jedoch im Süden,
wo das Land vor allem geprägt ist durch einen
Steppencharakter, ist das kaum möglich. Womit also
auch dieser Vorstoß über den Dnjepr relativ rasch
für die russischen Truppen möglich war. Diese vier
Kernprobleme werden nun entscheidend sein für den
Verlauf der Kämpfe in den nächsten Wochen. Wenn es
den ukrainischen Streitkräften gelingt, Kiew zu
halten, den Dnjepr als starke Verteidigungslinie
zu halten und vielleicht die Kräfte sogar
über den Dnjepr wieder zurückzuwerfen, dann
könnten die Voraussetzungen geschaffen werden,
tatsächlich eine Verhandlungslösung zu erreichen,
die möglicherweise im schlimmsten Fall sicher
auch eine Teilung des Landes darstellt. An dieser
Stelle möchte ich enden. Ich sage danke fürs
Zuhören und auf Wiedersehen aus Wiener Neustadt.